so no so there were many things you know
the
they they twisted people's minds in all
kinds of ways in fact they're still
doing it in russia
but uh but i had good preparation for
that i had a good theoretical
preparation and most of all i had the
desire
i had the desire to know to to
understand i was curious a lot of the
other correspondents in moscow in those
days were absolutely miserable
they didn't want to be there they knew
that for the purposes of their careers
they had to
spend a couple of years in dreary
uninteresting moscow
the place where there were no decent
restaurants no decent stores nothing to
do
and where their wives were slow slowly
going crazy uh you know with boredom and
uh
and irritation which they vented of
course on their on their husbands
and
um
but i didn't look at it that way at all
i mean and and most of them didn't speak
russian they didn't make the effort
uh
but even with my level of knowledge when
i got there i realized that to really
operate in the society i would have to
master the language
and i met religiously with my russian
teacher and it was inconvenient it was
easy to cancel those lessons
but i understood that
that this was the key
i always think that that could be one of
the biggest barriers
especially not i mean mainly within the
media because there's so it's like
playing the game of telephone there's so
many layers of people that are
digesting information repurposing it for
headlines that most people don't read
past the headlines and then before all
that you have the whole language barrier
like how accurate are the people that
are interpreting what these russians are
saying how accurate
is the translation before you get to all
the media
you know
yeah i mean i'll give you a good example
we had this uh reset policy with
president obama
uh
there was tension in relations between
russia and the u.s and obama's view was
that this was the fault of
his predecessor george bush in fact
obama when he came into office was
blaming everything in under the sun on
george bush
and
uh
and so he announced a new policy and was
called the policy of reset now boris
nemtsov
a russian democratic leader who was
murdered
in february 2015 and i
we met with we talked to
a guy
who i won't name who was
going to be
obama's chief russian adviser
and we told him
and at that time there was already talk
about a so-called reset
and we told him that that that
you know putin is not a
can a candidate for partnership he he's
a candidate for deterrence
and of course he he he didn't want to
hear any of it and then in his career
was tied up with of course
uh supporting whatever obama
uh uh desired but who was do who you're
speaking about
this is i i i since i know him
personally i prefer it's one of the top
top one of the top advisors
uh you know who who was behind the reset
policy okay and the reset policy was the
idea that we were going to change you
know re-examine our positions and try to
meet the russians halfway you know
well uh uh
you know it basically we were
attributing an american psychology to
the russians assuming that we will meet
them halfway they'll respond and and all
the problems will be solved you know we
just have to show a little good will no
understanding of who the russian leader
was
what the his background was what he had
done what what he was likely to do in
the future and then to top everything
off when they announced the reset policy
uh
hillary clinton presented a red button
to sergey lavrov who was the russian
foreign minister
uh with the with the word reset in
russian uh
uh with a word
uh for reset in russian that was
incorrect
uh
uh
it was i mean in russian it was
peregruska and it reset me is paris
aguruska but you know for it's
uh just the kind of unprofessional
uh
and this was presented by
the sec
the secretary of state because hillary
clinton was the secretary of state to
the russian foreign minister
uh and to show
uh
how you know how how sensitive we are to
russian culture and of course
uh
the the word that we chose was um
that you know for our policy was
mistranslated and the the the russian
word that was you know on the gift on
the red button was not the correct word
do you know what the actual word was
like what it actually translated to in
russian
uh yeah um paragruska it's reload
but
is resetting something the the uh
whereas uh
uh pierre gruska is is uh
you know just plugging something into a
wall so that you know
you know you'll get you'll
you'll get the charge back
in any case i mean just typical but this
is it goes to your point
because
from the very top
i mean how can we expect the media
to be
well informed how can we expect the
public discussion in the u.s to be well
informed
in a situation in which the government
is so unprofessional
and uh let's face it understanding
russia is not simple yeah it takes it
takes work
the famous mark twain quote uh
if you don't read the newspaper you're
uninformed if you do read the newspaper
you're misinformed
yeah it shouldn't be that way
it shouldn't be that way
but
in fact
you know just awful stuff i mean there
was re recently a big article in the new
york times
a 7 000 word piece about explaining
vladimir putin
and his rise to power not a single word
about the apartment bombings which are
the real reason why he came to power why
do you think that is
i think that you know people uh
reject
and are openly hostile
to things they don't understand or that
are really outside their family outside
their familiar
uh
kind of frame of reference
and they even take
you know penetration serious analysis as
a challenge
and some in some cases even a personal
challenge
uh
and react with hostility to any attempt
really
to you know
to look at a serious question in a
serious way